aquí tenemos una suma 26 más 18 54 y
podemos evaluar esto y sumarlo pero lo
que quiero hacer es usarla para
practicar la escritura de una serie como
esta en notación sigma así que pensemos
en lo que está pasando aquí veamos si
podemos observar algún patrón de un
término al otro vamos a ver para pasar
del 2 al 6 podríamos decir que estamos
sumando 4 pero luego cuando pasamos del
6 al 18
ahora estamos sumando 12 así que no es
una serie aritmética tal vez es una
serie geométrica así que para ir del 2
al 6 que estamos haciendo bueno estamos
multiplicando por 3 y para pasar al 18
que estamos haciendo bueno estamos
multiplicando por 3 y para ir del 18 al
54 estamos multiplicando por tres
entonces lo que vemos aquí es sin duda
una serie geométrica y tenemos una razón
común igual a 3 así que vamos a
reescribir esto usando notación sigma
esto va a ser una suma y hay muchas
maneras en que podemos escribir esto
podemos escribirlo empezando con acá
igual a cero y tenemos nuestro primer
término que es 2 por nuestra razón común
elevada a la potencia acá así que antes
de que escriba cuántos términos tenemos
aquí que tanto vamos a avanzar con
nuestra acá vamos a ver si esto tiene
sentido cuando k es igual a cero esto va
a ser igual a 2 por 3 a la potencia 0
que es lo mismo que 2 por 1 y que es
nuestro primer término que tenemos aquí
cuando k es igual a 1
eso sería igual a 2 por 3 a la potencia
1 y bueno eso es igual a 6
cuando caes igualados bueno lo voy a
escribir aquí arriba esto es igual a
cero
este es k igual a 1 k igualados
y acá 3 que sería 2 por 3 a la tercera
potencia 2 por 27 es igual a 54 así que
tenemos que llegar hasta que acá sea
igual a 3 entonces esta es una manera en
que podemos escribir esto pero hay otras
maneras y otra sería aquí tenemos
nuestro primer término y lo
multiplicamos por nuestra razón común
pero esta vez usaré un índice diferente
digamos que elevaremos a la potencia n
1 y en lugar de iniciar en cero voy a
iniciar n igual a 1 pero noten que tiene
el mismo efecto cuando decimos que n es
igual a 1 aquí uno menos 1 es igual a 0
y obtenemos la potencia 0
solamente incrementamos los índices en 1
así que en lugar de ir de 0 a 3 vamos a
ir de 1 a 4 y puedes verificar que esto
funciona porque cuando en es igual a 4
aquí nos queda 3 elevado a la potencia 4
menos uno que es igual a la tercera
potencia y es igual a 27 por 2 es igual
a 54
aquí tenemos n1 n2
n igual a tres
y n4 pero de cualquier manera estas son
formas que podemos usar para escribir
notación sigma